o kiss magro tudo óptimo do universo de
melancia em trecho do sul
o laço alguém fala o dark seja muito
bem-vindo instalação b ó eu quero
construir um espaço com fundamentos com
coisas para construir é porque tem muita
idéia se mantém na questão de quem vai
ele traz vai ser um laboratório que eu
vou fazer experiências químicas físicas
tudo que o player mais enquanto está em
obras é preciso continuar a fazer vídeo
tanto vai fazer um vídeo
eu tenho uma ideia muito boa olha só o
piloto de fafe por uma loja de
brinquedos e eu encontrei estas bombas
né mas isso não convenceu na época
esteve das crianças consigamos
conseguisse ter força do lucro portanto
pessoal hoje eu estar aqui as luvas do
que vamos ver quanta força o google pode
ter é ó assunto porque o que está a
fazer um acompanhamento de uma criança
que traz com super força eu não acredito
que isso foi assim tanta força porque
porque extensão e corta ético mas agora
ser pessoal teve uma coisa muito bonita
frustrar e ethernet
vocês terão que vir em minha obra prima
e minha convidar deixam rastros olha só
eu falar da frente fria se desloque
fatos bizarros
os tubarões na água dormir senão
ficávamos é bom é assunto dos 90 quilos
ficou por linha corta pela carga mais do
que eu mas essas obras de 12 dos fatos
bizarros que vocês podem encontrar aqui
no meu livro incluindo muito experientes
mesmo que vocês podem fazer em casa só
se um cinto e espero ter equilíbrio
neste momento está em pré venda portanto
fazem simplesmente estão na descrição
vocês podem comprar lá eles fazem é
comprar em pré venda
dez por cento de desconto no livro e
ainda conseguir um livro autografado é
porque já tive outubro foram muitos
livros para quem comprar a pré-venda e
pra quem quiser comprar o livro está
comigo dia 24 de março já este mês eu
vou estar na fnac do colombo vai passar
aqui toda a informação eu vou estar lá
com uma sessão de autógrafos do livro
portanto passei lá será preciso muito
vocês mesmo então o preço atual 24 de
março fraco do comando e previna do
livro está na descrição bola para fora
tão pessoal que está nas nossas lutas do
útero vou tentar abrir embalagens óculos
de sol é o cruzmaltino tudo 201/202
presente bola lançou o primeiro texto
vai ser uma tábua de madeira e é bem
flexível portanto eu acho que vai ser
fácil para o preto do socorro
como é que eu conseguiria tamanho em
três temporadas foi feito para uma só a
próxima coisa que vou tentar destruir
com o suco do uc vai ser uma coca-cola
normal é uma cola é um até se eu
conseguir levantar e se qualquer um suco
eu acho que esse clube
eu acho que se temos mesmo assim coloca
como muito dura é muito distinto mas
vamos sentar para abril abriu exulto
olha aí porto decide agora 32
[Música]
ela ficou completamente dispensável
unisul é muito forte como é que é
possível é muito forte destruiu
completamente a até r 15
olha aí e eu acho que a pessoa que está
fazer esta obra vai ficar chateada
porque eu estou sujar tudo frisa da
partida onde está toda pronta
[Música]
o orós uma coisa para destruir uma caixa
de óxi é você já sabe o que vai
acontecer veja que está tudo uma sujeira
já vamos aproveitar agora o cruz maltino
tudo mas eu sou como ficou atrás com
rubro que até então não tinha placa na
rua do gesso para não perder do maior
laboratório e está tudo isso já quando o
homem do brasil tá muito estranho mas o
contrário
esta mão tem lugar pra mim e não é nosso
aí eu tô confuso é a minha cabeça estava
em casa até porque mexe o braço
magistrado é e só que na câmara a
contrair se e para nós só vamos
continuar a destruir coisas mas a
próxima coisa que nós vamos destruir a
nossa amiga melancia
[Música]
an mas eu sou contra a nossa melancia
como o time tinha um quadro com silva
teve tamanha presença na mesa já tem
aqui coca cola tem um novo e eu ainda
vou sujar com o lance e ela não quer
a bola só o sogro do universo de
melancia em 32 sul possui muito bom em
todo o mundo milhões de espécies se
enfrentam na natureza em uma luta
selvagem pela sobrevivência eles caçam
de tudo sem hesitar
desde um lanchinho até uma refeição
completa e um carona de chitato sul
olha que educação todos os provocam sul
e agora vocês vão ver o pior era só
[Música]
muito em baixo se isto está mais do lado
do cubo os quartos não tiver comentei
que não está se estiver comitê que está
vamos ver quantas pessoas que dormem em
cima do lixo ou escolher um pacote de
batata frita mas naquela época fazia
isso não sei porquê da pergunta dar
sukiyaki no lance wesley já que está
sujeito jamais nem todos os testes
físicos jogos do huck eu fiz como e acho
que eu seria mais ou menos o que
acontecer né explodir mas agora vamos
realmente testar com costuras com coisas
que não é possível reinventar como uma
manta plástica e voltar agora é quebrar
aquela pedro cônsul aquela pedra lá a
acho que vou conseguir
vocês podem se movimentar consegue ou
não consegue envolver quando as pessoas
confiam em mim eu vou ver e eu vou
quebrar meu pulso hora eu vou quebrar
minha costa à época do sul quarto
psicólogo acho verdade eu não sei mas
uns a bola sol ou esmaga tudo 32 o
status de vôo não está a funcionar só
não vamos continuar a tentar
a lei também valha
mas nada de grave crise tenham esquerda
e também não consigo
[Música]
só olha eu estou muito cansado
o fato é servida de uva tô cansado
porque este vírus que as outras coisas
né as suas pensões é fácil leitura só
faz vídeo destruir é também ela fazer
igual a você consegue mais as sólidas
para que o sistema não está aqui neste
vídeo comprei um livro quero ganhar
dinheiro para comer pão primas vai pagar
esta casa porque é muito caro né casa
grande china tão comprei um livro
pessoal dos links estão aí na descrição
vocês podem comprar nessas duas lojas em
nuuk na final mas já espero que vocês
tenham gostado filho é aproximar
[Música]